hier soir alors qu'on pensait sans
dormir tranquille au biel ou pour faire
de jolis rêves les chaînes infos ont
basculé en mode breaking news je déchire
mes notes déchire mes notes nous venons
d'apprendre il ya quelques minutes que
le premier ministre de la france jean
castex venait d'être testés positifs au
co vide et oui ça peut arriver même au
premier ministre qui pourtant avait les
bons tuyaux pour lutter contre
l'épidémie il faut respecter tous les
gestes barrière bas sauf qu'il a dû
zapper ses propres conseils visiblement
car ces derniers jours il a serré
énormément de paluches
on va pas se mentir à sa foutue un petit
peu le bazar au sein du gouvernement
tout ça gérald darmanin eric
dupond-moretti roselyne bachelot ou
encore florence parly au total ils sont
dix ministres ou secrétaires d'état être
qu'à contacter du coup forcément les
journalistes qui recevait les politiques
qu'ils étaient un petit peu ingrat sera
quand même jean castex positif vous avez
terre-neuve-et-labrador positif vous
n'êtes pas qu'à contacter et comme si ça
ne suffisait pas après la politique
c'est le monde du sport qui est en
panique totale à cause de la présence de
jean castex week-end au stade de france
il s'est même rendu dans les vestiaires
après le match pour fêter la troisième
mi temps aux côtés de jean dujardin qui
va sûrement devoir y aller de son petit
test antigénique le jeannot c'est un
bordel
[Applaudissements]
prenez-vous ceux qui le critiquent sur
son manque de précaution janot alors
insupportable que deux ans quelques
bidons sont encore à reprocher aux gens
de serrer des mains de faire la bise de
pratiquer la délation ce que c'est de la
délation et voilà donc soit en fait on
arrête d'être fou dans les ces gens
vivraient se faire la bise sont dit que
le coc vide a tué tout le monde et on
enferme les gens comme il ya deux ans
mais arrêtez d des hypocrites tout le
monde en boîte de nuit tombée au
restaurant sauvé la vie il a passé
15 premiers mais alors c'est donc la
valeur évidemment donc
mon père donc il faut il faut montrer
l'exemple évidemment ils doivent
redoubler de vigilance évidemment il
doit se laver les mains 75 fois par jour
évidemment il doit faire le attention le
plus possible et notamment il ya une
séquence où on le voit dans une salle
close où personne n'a de match c'est le
premier ministre il doit montrer
l'exemple lui désolé de leurs ébats
normal que ça c'est quoi j'ai presque
envie de faire entrer la secrétaire a
demandé son avocat
contacté par madame des personnes
n'étant failli correction qui a consacré
meilleur côté d'elisabeth montreynaud je
me souviens qu'on aura pas de retraite
histoire on va faire ce débat avec l
ministre délégué auprès du ministre
après on parlera bien sûr de ce que
pourquoi ce don pour aller mieux mais on
peut lui poser la question elle est
chargée de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes et la diversité et de
l'égalité des chances donc voilà les
responsables de plein de choses
elisabeth
[Musique]
chapelle saint paul je voulais
rencontrer il avec moreno je suis seule
voix les listes ici justement on n'est
pas à droite on pas gauche on s'en fout
voilà où on voit des ddd des personnes
et je la trouve je le dit extrêmement
talentueuse non mais c'est vrai savez ce
qu'on dit de vous non non on dit quoi là
on dit que vous êtes pour vous peut-être
une prochaine président tout
présidentiable dans quelques années
voilà là ne me mettez pas la pression là
lorsque jean puis ce que j'apprécie dans
ce que vous dites déjà c'est que mes
sujets ne sont ni de droite ni de gauche
parce que quand on parle d'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes quand on parle
de diversité et de la pluralité notre
pays et quand on parle d'égalité des
chances ça concerne tous les français et
j'ai suffisamment à faire avec ces
sujets là croyez le bien c'est ça alors
ils savent être est ce que vous n'êtes
qu'à contacter les voeux jean castex je
ne suis pas qu'à contacter
jeu je vous aurais pas renié ça quand
même je vous ai entendu un peu lorsque
j'étais dans le couloir et vous avez
tous un peu raison ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que moi ça fait quatorze mois
que je travaille avec jean castex il est
extrêmement impliqué dans cette question
de crise sanitaire il travaille
quasiment 24 heures sur 24
week-end compris et je trouve bon c'est
un être humain il est qu'à contacter
aujourd'hui il a été contaminé par sa
fille en plus on va pas en rajouter sur
les épaules de sa fille parce que je
pense qu'on a suffisamment dit comme ça
et c'est malheureux mais ça ne m'empêche
pas de travailler ça ne les empêche pas
d'être attaché de continuer de faire ce
qu'il a à faire pour sortir notre pays
de cette situation extrêmement difficile
ça va on vous sait que si vous n'êtes
pas venu pour ça mais on est on est
extrêmement inquiet parce qu'on entend
par là plein de choses on voit les cas
de plus en plus nombreux on parlait
d'ailleurs dans cette émission
le gouvernement est à fond vraiment là
dessus en ce moment c'est on est à fond
on est à fond on surveille tout on
regarde tout on comptabilise tous
les français ont fait des efforts
colossaux ces deux dernières années on a
vécu et on est encore en train de vivre
des moments extrêmement difficiles
monsieur le disais tout à l'heure
et oui le monsieur enfin normalement
on a traversé deux années extrêmement
difficiles où on a tous appris ensemble
on a appris en marchant on sait
aujourd'hui que le vaccin et l'on va
dire la meilleure arme contre ce virus
je salue tous les français qui se sont
vaccinés il faut que nous continuons
d'être solidaires dans cette bataille
parce que c'est la seule manière de s'en
sortir alors madame le secrétaire d'état
qui sait si ministre un ministre ou là
où
vous êtes mis je me suis suffisamment
battu pour m'élever dans la société pour
que vous avez reçue alors miss alors oui
j'ai ben voilà j'avais mal lu ou êtes
ministre et je vous le confirme
aujourd'hui
[Rires]
c'est bon
madame annie il avait été choisi par qui
par jean castex ou par le chef de l'état
les deux et de jean castex et le chef du
gouvernement le président de la
république voir défier emmanuel macron
alors c'est le président de la
république qui m'a repéré lors
exactement voilà c'est lui qui m'a
repéré lors d'une conférence sur les
diasporas justement avec le président
qui veut un coup de coeur pour vous je
vous lire non mais vraiment pas vraiment
ils
essaient ils dit vraiment que vous êtes
extrêmement tant que c'est pas un secret
on dit que vous êtes fait partie
vraiment dedans le gouvernement des
ministres qui trouve voilà qu'il aime
exposer parce qu'ils trouvent que vous
exprimez extrêmement bien que vous
expliquez bien les choses et que les
français vous comprenne c'est à dire que
vous avez un langage qui vous n'êtes pas
chiante vous dire la vérité je veux
c'est vrai franchement il ya des hyènes
il y en a d'autres c'est la crise c'est
compliqué et c'est vrai que vous quand
vous dites un truc on a tendance à vous
écouter parce que vous avez vous parlé
comme tout n'est pas langue de bois ça
n'exonère donc là écoutez moi je viens
de 30 ans dans la société civile j'ai
travaillé toute ma vie j'ai grandi dans
un quartier j'ai grandi dans une cité
petites filles noires à qui on dit ouh
là si tu arrive déjà à faire quelque
chose de ta vie estime toi heureux j'ai
pas voulu me contenter de ça je sais ce
que c'est que le sens de l'effort je
sais ce que c'est que le travail mes
parents m'ont appris des valeurs
extrêmement forte qui m'ont permis de
devenir ce que je suis aujourd'hui
est-ce que je vais me travestir parce
que je suis en politique certainement
pas parce que finalement qu'est-ce que
c'est que la politique si ce n'est pas
s'occuper des gens est ce que c'est
est-ce que ça n'est pas ça notre rôle
fondamental aujourd'hui donc comme je
viens de d'un environnement où je
comprends les souffrances les
difficultés les galères que l'on peut
tous et toutes à voir eh bien je parle
aux gens à langage que j'aimerais
entendre et que je voulais entendre
lorsque je n'étais pas en politique